Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bilal Altan.
Ich bin hier auf dieser Station als Diensthabenderarzt tätig.
Ich würde mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich, gerne.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerenssprechen,
möchte ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Bauer.
Bauer.
B A U E R.
Nachname?
Mein Vorname ist Thomas.
Thomas mit T H.
T H, genau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wo sind Sie?
Ich bin am 1. Dritten 1969 geboren.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich wiege momentan 90 Kilogramm.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 71.
Herr Bohr, wo sind Sie von Beruf nicht?
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich habe ein Unternehmen, wir verkaufen Hosen.
Darf ich Ihr Familienstand fragen?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe eine Tochter.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit 3 Tagen Schmerzen im unteren Bauch.
Können Sie genau diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie stetschend dumpf?
Ja, das sind dumpf und stechende Schmerzen.
Die werden immer mehr.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen auf eine Schmerz zu können bewerten?
Die Schmerzen sind sehr leicht und die Schmerzen sind sehr stark.
Sie sind schon bei 8, 7, 8.
Sind die Schmerzen da?
Ich habe bemerkt, wenn ich nichts esse,
werden die etwas besser.
Aber sobald ich etwas trink, werden die nicht mehr.
Aber die sind immer da und werden immer stärker.
Herr Bohr, ist Ihnen ein Ölbild oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein.
Sie haben schon gesagt, im unteren Bauch.
Die linken Seite oder die rechten Seite?
Die linken Seite.
Strahlen die Schmerzen vorhin?
Nein.
Wann werden die Schmerzen vorhin?
Sie sind im Unterbauch links.
Sie sind nur da.
Ich habe auch selber geduldet, aber ich habe sie nur im linken Unterbauch.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ich habe das immer.
Ich habe ein bisschen Blut verloren.
Aber das habe ich immer.
Das ist nicht neu.
Blut verloren.
Wenn ich auf Toilette bin, habe ich ein bisschen Blut verloren.
Aber das habe ich schon seit 5 Jahren immer wieder.
Ist Ihre Stuhl hellrot?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie ein Blutverdrucker?
Nein.
Ich nehme ein Blutverdrucker.
Wie heißt das Medikament?
Xarelto.
Haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Ja.
Ich habe ein Blutdrucker.
Ich habe eine Rhythmusstörung am Herzen festgestellt.
Ich nehme diese Blutverdünne ein.
Seit 3 Jahren?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie ein Medikament gegen Bluthoff?
Ich nehme 2 Medikamente ein.
Das ist einmal Aramipril.
Und HT, heißt das.
Ja, ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
HT 25 Millionen.
Ich glaube, 5 Millionen.
Beides morgens einmal.
Ja, ich möchte wieder Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden überkommen.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht verloren?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich immer konstant bei 90 Kilogramm.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Ob ich Nachtschwitze?
Nein.
Ja, das ist heiß momentan, deswegen vielleicht aber sonst.
Normalerweise nicht.
Draußen ist das Wetter heiß.
Deswegen schwitzen wir alle, glaube ich.
Fühlen Sie sich viel bricht?
Ich habe Fieber gehabt.
Gestern Abend habe ich Fieber gehabt.
Haben Sie sich schon gemessen?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, nein, aber ich fühle mich jetzt auch krank.
Wie ist Ihre Schlafen? Können Sie gut schlafen?
Jetzt in den letzten 3 Tagen nicht so gut, aber normalerweise schon.
Hab ich keine Probleme.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Eigentlich unverändert, ist okay.
Ich esse zu viel, glaube ich.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben im Stuhl Blut gesehen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Ja, ich habe momentan eher Durchfall, aber ich habe auch vorher Verstopfung gehabt.
Momentan habe ich hier ein bisschen Durchfall.
Okay, Herr Bohr.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie bekannte chronische Erkrankungen?
Also, meine Eltern sind gestorben.
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Mein Vater hatte etwas am Herzen gehabt.
Meine Mutter hatte Demenz.
Wie alt waren Sie, als Sie gestorben sind?
Mein Vater war ungefähr 85 Jahre alt und meine Mutter mit 80 Jahren gestorben.
Herr Bohr, gibt es im Alltag etwas, was Sie seelisch belastet?
Momentan eigentlich nicht so, nicht, was auffällig ist.
Das ist wie immer eigentlich.
Okay.
Ramiprin, hsht und nehmt sie.
Und Blutverdöner?
Ja, Blutverdöner, Achser-Reltinier.
Und gibt es noch Medikamente, noch andere Medikamente, die Sie eingenommen haben?
Nein. Also, ich habe mich jetzt seit drei Tagen nämlich Ibuprofen ein bisschen ein,
weil ich starke Schmerzen habe, aber ansonsten nehme ich normalerweise nichts ein.
Nehmen Sie eine Dosierung Ibuprofen?
Ich weiß nicht mehr. 500, 600.
Ich habe das nicht im Kopf, hat mir zu Hause, habe ich eingeschaut.
Meine Frau hat mir das gegeben.
Okay. Ibuprofen, nehmen Sie oft oder?
Nur, wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Okay. Herr Bohr, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viel Zigaretten täglich rauchen?
Ja, so eine halbe Schachtel.
Seit wann?
Schon lange, also ich habe auch mehr mal geraucht.
Jetzt rauche ich weniger.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich rauche seitdem ich 20 bin, glaube ich.
Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, auch schon lange.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Am Wochenende manchmal.
Was trinken Sie?
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, es kommt immer darauf an, Bier oder Wein.
Kommt immer darauf an, also es ist nicht mehr das Gleiche.
Okay.
Nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Herr Bohr, nehmen Sie bitte nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen, nein, nicht das Fürste.
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie eine Allergie haben, Herr Bohr,
oder Unverzweglichkeiten gegen den Stimmen?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Bohr.
Meine Sesse habe ich alle Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch, haben Sie Fragen
oder möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Was ist das, was ich habe? Kann das Krebs sein?
Ja, Herr Bohr, zurzeit, leider kann ich nicht diese Frage beantworten,
weil es ist zu früh, etwas zu sagen.
Und ich möchte zuerst Sie körperlich untersuchen
und von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen für Anlass,
wie Ultraschall oder gegebenenfalls Kompetentomographie.
Und dann können wir ausführlich besprechen
und über Ihre Diagnose und Therapiemöglichkeiten.
Ich dann, glauben Sie denn, das schon hier bleiben muss,
ich muss nach Hause gehen.
Ich möchte noch arbeiten.
In der Zwischenzeit wäre es besser, wenn Sie hier bei uns bleiben.
Also stationär bleiben, ja?
Ja, stationär bleiben.
Okay, okay, verstanden.
Okay.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen in der Hand herfragen?
Ich wurde noch nie operiert.
Ja, ich würde nicht.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Also Blutabgänge habe ich schon seit fünf Jahren ungefähr,
aber diese Bauchschmerzen sind neu.
Ich habe auch noch nie eine Kolloskopie gehabt,
falls Sie fragen möchten.
Ja, ich wollte mal, ich habe vergessen.
Haben Sie Sehstörungen?
Sehstörungen?
Neun.
Also jetzt Alterssehstörungen, wenn ich lese,
muss ja eine Brille tragen.
Gelenkschmerzen?
Gelenkschmerzen habe ich, wenn ich zu viel arbeite,
aber sonst nicht.
Jetzt bei Ihnen hat es oder Mundschleimhaut,
oft ist es eine geschwürweise Lokalisation oder etwas bekannt?
Ich habe keine Hauptveränderungen in einem Mundschleimhaut.
Nein, das ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Ich mache auch nicht viel Sport.
Also ich bin eher auf der Arbeit und zu Hause.
Ich fahre manchmal Fahrrad.
Ich habe eine sitzende Tätigkeit.
Also ich bin eher im Büro und arbeite dort.
Welche Diagnose hat Sie gestartet?
Wo?
Wegen ich es.
Blut.
Achso, ich habe, der Hausarzt hat gesagt, ich habe Hemorrhoiden.
Hemorrhoid?
Hat er mir gesagt, ja.
Aber da ich keine Schmerzen habe, haben wir nichts gemacht.
Haben Sie eine solche Gefühle?
In den letzten drei Tagen, meinen Sie jetzt?
Ja, General und lesson.
Also, ich habe nicht so eine Gefühle.
Aber in den letzten drei Tagen habe ich, wie gesagt,
wenn ich etwas esse, habe ich dann Bauchschmerzen.
Ich habe noch völlig gefühlt und muss Winde lassen.
Flatulenz.
Aber das hilft mir.
Das tut dann ein bisschen gut, wenn ich Winde lassen kann.
Können Sie Ihre Durchfallgenar bezeichnen?
Also ich habe eher so schleimigen Durchfall in den letzten drei Tagen.
Aber was mich wundert, ist ja vorher normalerweise immer so,
dass ich immer verstopfe und jetzt habe ich Durchfall.
Das wundert mich ein bisschen.
Wie oft am Tag gehen Sie zu heute?
Also in den letzten drei Tagen, so zwei Mal.
Ich war auch nicht im Ausland, falls Sie fragen möchten.
Ich bin hier gewesen.
Ich war nicht im Urlaub oder auf Geschäftsreise.
Und noch etwas bekommen Sie Durchfall und Verstoffung Beschwerden?
Immer in Wechsel?
Nein, wie gesagt, ich habe normalerweise ja Verstopfung,
aber jetzt in drei Tagen habe ich Durchfall.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestärbt,
können wir erst als Gesiebte anfangen?
Natürlich.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen
und ich möchte ihn vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Natürlich.
Thomas Bauer ist 50-jähriger Patient.
Ja, 40.
44.
Ja.
44-jährige Patient.
Kann zu uns wegen seit drei Tagen Bestehende
und Zähnende, Zunehmende, Abdominalschmerzen
im Unterenbau, Astrakbegriff habe ich nicht gesehen.
Linken Unterbau?
Ja, linken Unterbau.
Wie Schmerzen sein, Dummstechende
und dauerhaft da.
Und wie Schmerzen sein, meistens nach dem Essen
und Trinken ausgetreten.
Aus dem Klagte der Patient über Hematoshesia
und die hätte der Patient Verstoffung
und seit drei Tagen hätte ein Durchfall.
Nehmen Sie X-Reltung als Blutverdünne.
Er wurde früher ein Koloskopi nicht durchgeführt
und er lag über Völlegefühl und Lehungen.
An Vorerkrankungen hat der Patient Bluthochdruck seit 10 Jahren
und Rhythmusstörungen seit drei Jahren
und er wurde nicht operiert.
An Familienanamnese ergab,
bei Vater ein Herzbeinfahrt und bei Mutter Demenz
und Vater mit 85 gestorben.
Mutter mit 80 gestorben, aber die Ursache weiß ich nicht.
Bei Vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig
bis auf Schlafstörung wegen dieser Beschwerden seit drei Tagen
und als Medikament der Nähe von Bril
und Ramitril 5 mg morgens
und Hydrochlorotheasit 25 mg morgens
und gegen diese Beschwerden habe er im Gefühneingenommen
und X-Reltung als Blutverdünne.
Der Patient erhaucht seit 26. Lebensjahr
und er hat ein Fakten, den Siggarette einpackt.
Er hat 35 Päckchen, Gelegenheit und Alkohol
und der Leuchttür hat getragen
und er hat keine Allergien.
Und er war in der letzten Zeit nicht im Ausland und er macht viel Sport.
Er macht viel Sport?
Nein, nichts.
Kein Sport.
Nein, Sport.
Kein Sport, ja.
Ja, umerst.
Was, wie sind denn die Schmerzen?
Hat er sehr starke Schmerzen?
Oder ist es eher so gleichbleibend?
Wie würden Sie ihn einschätzen?
Auf der Schmerz-Intensivität wurde mit sechs Bewerten.
Okay, sieben bis acht.
Okay, also schon sehr starke Schmerzen.
Was glauben Sie denn und was er hat?
Oder was haben Sie mit dem Vorbild der Arbeitstheatmose?
Nach einem nächsten Angaben.
Ein Moment, bitte.
Herr Kollege, ich möchte auch kurz zusammenfassen, wenn Sie mich entschuldigen.
Okay.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen seit drei Tagen bestehender, fokredienter,
ausprandialer Abdominal Schmerzen im Linken Unterbau folgestellt.
Abdominal Schmerzen?
Abdominal Schmerzen.
Außerdem beschirbt er die Schmerzen als durf und stechend.
Okay.
Die Schmerz-Intensivität, die er auf der NRS beinhaltet,
hat sie mit acht, zehn Bewerten.
Er hat eine Art von 800 mg, die er in einem
Aufgrund, aufgrund.
Aufgrund.
Ich würde noch hinzufügen, der Patient,
der
Progadient der
linkszeitiger,
nahrungsabhängiger
Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Er hat dir erzählt,
dass es besser wird,
schlimmer wird.
Das ist auch okay.
Bitte schön.
Entschuldigung.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Die Hämorrhoide
hat der Patient, oder?
Er hat ja schon jahrelang Hämorrhoide
leideneidend Blutungen.
Hat sein Hausarzt festgestellt,
hatte Herr Dr.
Gundes nach nachgefragt.
Das hatten Sie nicht nachgefragt.
Ich glaube, ja.
Anonystisch in Angaben gehe ich
einem Verdacht auf
Ulcus
Pepticus aus
als
Diagnose.
Als Diagnose
kommen
die Vertikulitis,
Apandicitis oder
Poloncharcinum in Betracht.
Wie kommen Sie auf Ulcus ventriculi
als erste Diagnose?
Hat der Oberbauchschmerz oder Unterbauchschmerzen?
Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ja, richtig.
Dann will ich die Diagnose umstellen.
Was würden Sie als erste Stelle nehmen?
Apandicitis.
Wo ist der Appendix?
Rechts oder links?
Rechts.
Solange der Patient
die Diagnose umstellt,
muss man von rechtszeitigen Schmerzen
abbeziehen.
Was haben wir denn zu Organe auf der linken Seite?
In der linken Organe gibt es Rektum,
Polondescendence
und Milz
und Sigma.
Sigma gibt es auch.
Bei den Rektum sind die
Rektum, die Rektum, die Rektum.
Sigma gibt es auch.
Nieren gibt es auch.
Auf der linken Seite.
Der Patient beschreibt,
was sie mir erzählt haben.
Das ist schon lange hemorrhidaleiten.
Mit Helarot und Blut.
Und seit 3 Tagen bestehen
wir die Diagnose umstellt.
Hat der Patient Besymptomatik?
Er hat keine Gewichtverlust
und keinen Nachtschweiß.
Also kein Besymptomatik?
Kein Besymptomatik.
Wir können von einem
schwerwägenden Prozess absehen.
Aber wir müssen trotzdem das kontrollieren.
Unsere Diagnose wäre hier am
wahrscheinlichsten was?
Was glauben Sie?
Ein Abzess?
Kann sein.
Aber aufgrund welcher Erkrankung
könnte ein Abzess haben.
Aufgrund einer Diweticulitis.
Wissen Sie, was die Diweticulitis ist?
Die Diweticulitis ist ein
Wand,
in darmen Wand gibt es
einen
Defekt wie ein Ballon.
Das sind so Ausstültungen
der Darmband, der Darmbokosa.
Die können sich manchmal entzünden.
Man spricht von einer Diweticulose,
wenn die Darmband ausgestülpt ist.
Wenn sie entzündet ist, nennt man das Diweticulitis.
Ich würde von dieser Diagnose ausgehen.
Aber man muss trotzdem
bei Blutabgängen, auch wenn der Patient
hemorrhidaleiden hat, und noch nie
eine Darmspielung bekommen hat,
muss man auch überlegen, ob man eine Darmspielung macht
und um ein Kolonkarzinom auszuschließen.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
Ist das plausibel?
Ist das okay?
Ich würde bei diesem Patient
nach der körperlichen
Untersuchung
im Blutbild,
wegen eines Entzündungsparameters
oder Blutarmut,
eine Mier
und
möchte ich
eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Ich würde
jetzt eine Koloskopie nicht durchführen,
wenn der Patient eine Entzündung haben sollte.
Warum machen wir keine
Koloskopie, wenn der Patient eine Entzündung haben sollte?
Damit wir
eine Perforation
nicht riskieren.
Wenn der Darm,
das Sigma oder die Darm-Wart entzündet ist
und wir machen jetzt eine Koloskopie,
haben wir ein erhöhtes Risiko einer Perforation
und damit würden wir den Patient nicht
skutestun.
Wir können eine
Computotomografie
beurteilen.
Wir können aber vorher
ein Ultraschall des Abdomens
beurteilen.
Es sei denn, der Patient hat zu viel Luft im Bauch,
es ist schwer.
Wenn der Patient sehr adepös sein sollte,
dann würde er sich
einlegen.
Wenn wir von einer Diabeticulitis ausgehen
sollten,
welche Therapie würden Sie einleiten?
Zuerst muss ich den
Patienten stationieren aufnehmen
und
vielleicht nachher um Karrens machen.
Wir können
schnell möglichst
den Patienten operieren
und
wegen
müssen wir ihn operieren?
Nein, aber trotzdem
ist eine Narbe,
die wir nicht haben.
Wir wissen noch nicht, was da los ist.
Deswegen empfehlen wir den Patienten
eine Narbenskarenz einzuhalten.
Nein, Narbenskarenz.
Bei Diabeticulitis
sollten wir eine Narbenskarenz einhalten.
Wir können nicht
in die Diabeticulitis
einleiten.
Wir wissen nicht, wie ausgeprägt die
Diabeticulitis ist.
Wenn der Patient eine sehr ausgeprägt
oder perforierte Diabeticulitis hat,
die wir noch nicht wissen,
müssen wir eine Narbenskarenz empfehlen.
Am nächsten Tag,
wenn alles nach Schmerztherapie,
und nach Computertogymographie,
und Ultraschall besser geworden ist,
kann man einen Kostenaufformachen.
Wenn der Patient schmerzt,
von der Skala von 7 bis 8,
was geben wir ihm?
Schmerzmedikation.
Sollen wir weiter Ibuprofen geben?
Nein, ich würde den Patienten
mit Amisol oder
Parasitamol geben.
Nach der Diagnose
festgestellt haben,
können wir Schmerztherapie
mit Metamisol oder Parasitamol
verabreichen.
Verstanden.
Antibiotherapie ist schon ein
Problem.
Herr Kollege, ich würde sagen,
dass die Schmerz
von 8 bis 8
auf die Diagnose
verabreicht.
Ich würde sagen,
dass die Diagnose
residiert ist.
Ich würde sagen,
dass die Diagnose
nicht verabreicht.
Ich würde sagen,
dass die Patienten mit linkseitigem Unterbauchschmerzen
die Nahrungsabhängig sind.
Ich würde sagen, dass die
Nachnahungsaufnahme verstärkt ist.
Eine Komplikation,
Sie haben gesagt,
Perforation und danach eine Akutapie
ist ein Akkusabdomen.
Deswegen
residieren
nur Postbrand.
Das ist ja bei einer Diwetikulitis
nicht immer so.
Das ist nicht immer so, dass der Patient
Nahrungsabhängig-Schmerznachse ist.
Aber oft so,
dass der Patient sagt,
wenn ich etwas esse, wird das mehr.
Warum? Weil der Darm arbeitet,
Magen arbeitet, kontraiert der Darm.
Deswegen tut das weh.
Viele Patienten berichten, dass wenn sie nichts essen,
es ihnen besser geht.
Aber das muss nicht so sein.
Das hat nichts mit Residivieren zu tun.
Ich möchte mit Schmerztherapie
mit Antibiotika beginnen.
Sie haben recht.
Bei diesen Patienten,
wenn die Entzündungszeichen sehr hoch sein sollten,
würde ich auch Antibiotikum machen.
Muss man immer ein Antibiotikum machen
bei Diwetikulitis?
Wenn ein Entzündungs-Event
der Patient ein Entzündung hat,
müssen wir natürlich
einen Antibiotikum verabreicht.
Wenn er hohe Entzündungszeichen hat, Leukocytose,
Zerpäernstieg und auch diese Symptome hat,
haben Sie recht.
Ich würde dem Patient auch statt zu einer Aufnahme und Antibiotikum in Traveynus geben.
Es gibt aber auch Fälle,
wo die Diwetikulitis leicht verläuft.
Es gibt auch leichte Schmerzen,
die Skala von 4 bis 5, 3 bis 4.
Man kann auch die Stärken
mit regelmäßigen
ärztlichen Ambulanten kontrollen.
Nur dass sie das im Hinterkopf haben.
Diesen Patienten muss man wahrscheinlich
antibiotisch behandeln.
Welche Antibiotiko?
Man kann bei diesen Patienten
natürlich,
man kann am Pizzerien Solvactam geben.
Ich würde natürlich noch die Anärobia
mitnehmen
und den Metronidazolien.
Aber daher,
stationär, kann man auch Zephyroxin
intraveynös geben.
Statt am Pizzerien Solvactam.
Danke schön.
Kann man geben?
Es wird nicht mehr so oft empfohlen.
Wenn Sie das intraveynös geben, geht das.
Es ist kein Problem.
Aber Sie sollten das nicht mehr oral geben.
Bioverfügbarkeit ist sehr niedrig.
Das sollte nicht mehr so oft angewandt werden.
Die Therapie hat sich ein bisschen geändert.
Von daher muss man schauen,
welches, ob der Patient ambulant bleibt
oder ob der Patient stationär bleibt.
Wenn er stationär bleibt, würde ich ihm geben
Ziphyroxin oder Zephyroxin,
intraveynös plus Metronidazol.
Wenn er ambulant bleiben sollte, kann man
am Pizzerien Solvactam geben plus Metronidazol.
Bitte schön.
Eine große Probleme.
Ich denke,
dass der Patient ein genutzt wird.
Richtig.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Jeder Patient, der eine oral antikorrelation hat,
muss mit Vorsicht bedacht werden.
Frage hier, ob man Oralantikorrelation
weitermacht oder ob man das pausiert.
Stationär auf Heparien umswitscht.
Solange er stationär ist.
Ganz wichtig.
Sie haben auch gesagt,
dass er eine Herzrhythmusstörung hat.
Vielleicht habe ich das überhört, aber Sie müssen sagen,
warum oder welche Erkrankung das ist.
Ich habe nicht gehört,
dass die Vorrufe, die man gesagt haben.
Ich habe nicht gehört, dass die Vorrufe, die man gesagt haben,
eine Oralantikorrelation aufgrund von Vorrufen hat.
Danke schön.
Ich frage den Kollegen der Albin.
Herr Bayder,
ich habe eine Familie,
die eine Familie ist.
Ich habe eine Familie,
Wie ist es, wenn es die Familie gibt,
die Vater sprechen?
Ich würde, das ist immer unterschiedlich.
Wenn ich den Patienten vorstelle,
erwähne ich die Familie an der Mese,
nur wenn sie relevant ist.
Wenn der Vater ein Polonkarzinom hatte,
dann hätte ich das erwähnt.
Aber wenn der Patient, der Vater,
der Migräne leidet,
dann muss man das nicht erwähnen.
Das hat keine Relevanz.
Familienanmäse nur, wenn es relevant ist.
Gut.
Und noch eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt,
20 Jahre bin geraucht.
Oder vor 20 Jahren geraucht.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Nein, ich habe gesagt,
dass der Patient seit dem,
der 20 Jahre alt ist, geraucht.
Also der Rauch seit 34 Jahren schubbt.
Ja, seitdem ich 20 Jahre alt bin,
rauche ich schon.
Aber Sie haben,
welcher Geburtstil hat er?
Seit dem 20. Lebensjahr.
Ja, 17 Packungsjahres.
Ja, nicht 17 Packungsjahres.
Der ist 54 Jahre alt.
34 Jahre alt.
Ja, man muss überlegen,
mit diesem Package,
wie wichtig das ist in diesem Fall.
Ich meine, wenn man das nicht kennt,
ist es hier in diesem Fall.
Wenn wir jetzt über COPD sprechen würden,
oder über Lungenerkrankungen,
oder Herzkaiserkrankungen,
kann man dann natürlich ein bisschen penibler sein.
Aber wenn wir sagen, der Patient,
seit dem 20. Lebensjahr,
aktuell, manchmal können die Patienten das gar nicht richtig sagen.
Ich habe eine Packung geraucht, jeden Tag.
Ein Jahr habe ich eine halbe Packung geraucht.
Deswegen sollte man glaube ich nicht wirklich das rechnen.
Man sollte sagen ungefähr 34 Packages,
ungefähr 30 Packages,
als Orientierung.
Das ist meine Meinung.
Aber Sie sind Kardiologe, vielleicht sehen Sie das anders.
Vielleicht wollen Sie es unbedingt wissen, wie viel.
Ob das 34,5 Packages ist,
ich glaube, das ist jetzt in diesem Fall nicht so wichtig.
Wichtig ist das natürlich,
dass eine Sigma Geviticulitis durch Rauch und Begünstigung wird.
Das ist hier der entscheidende Punkt.
Der Patient hat keine Luftnot,
keine Angene Pectoris.
Es geht hier letztendlich um die Diagnose-Findung,
Diagnose-Stellung,
Nikotinkonsum, gleich,
vermehrtes Risiko für Sigma-Givitgulitis.
Das ist hier der anerlässliche Hintergrund.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das auch gesagt.
Falls ich etwas falsch gesagt habe, bitte um Korrektur.
Nein.
Eine Kollegin hat Pyrrexie schreiben.
Aber der ist nicht so gut.
Er ist nicht so gut.
Aber der Patient fühle ich mich fibrig.
Er ist nicht gemessen.
Genau.
translucent...
Was würde ich nicht schreiben?
Wie Sie schon richtig gesagt haben
der Patient habe sich fibrig gefühlt.
Fibrig gefühlt.
Okay.
Pyrexie kann man, glaube ich, nur sagen, wenn man das misst, wenn man jetzt drei, vier Mal am Tag gemessen hat und man hat immer 38, 39, 37, 38, das ist immer ein Zustand der erlöten Körpertemperatur.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht Pyrexie nennen.
Und Pyrexie bedeutet auf Deutsch Fieber am Fall schreiben, Fieber am Fall.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ja, weil, wer hat keinen Fieber-Anfall gehabt?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, Fieber am Fall schreiben.
Nein, er hat keinen Fieber-Anfall gehabt. Fieber-Anfall ist immer, wenn Sie zum Beispiel sagen, wir haben eine Erkrankung mit einem Tonselitis zum Beispiel, ein eitriger Tonselitis.
Ja, dann haben Sie immer Zwieber und Weck, Fieber und Weck zum Beispiel oder bei Malaria Rosolace zum Beispiel.
Diese automobile, Pyrexie, ist zum Beispiel eine Erkrankung mit einem Tonselitis, die die Erkrankung mit einem Tonselitis auf dem Beispiel, ein eitriger Tonselitis grape.
Pyrexie, etwas ist mitgekimmt.